i
actually started fixing my credit from
federal prison did you really
i started making steps like setting up
credit builder accounts i don't know if
i should say that
so you know making trying to make the
right steps like i set up a
what's a credit builder account like
self.com okay
or self.inc i think is what it is you
know you set up a it's like a loan
it's a it's a cd every month you put 150
bucks into it
and then after a year it unlocks you get
the money back or you can roll it over
into a prepaid card
all of that payment activity goes to
build your credit profile
so you know part of it was understanding
what really contributed to building
credit what it meant
because you know negative items is one
thing
having positive history is another and
both things are equally as important
so i read books on it and multiple books
and i and i learned what i needed to do
to get my credit looking right and it
worked
and you know and it's it's not hard it's
just it's just a matter of taking the
time to do it
yeah and it's the smartest thing you
could do because everything is dependent
on your credit whether you're going to
to buy a place and you want a low
interest rate on a mortgage or
you know you're going to buy a car that
that
one point you know one percent in
interest makes a big difference in your
payment oh hell yeah
so having a good credit rating is
important especially as a felon because
that's
now as a felon most hoas in the country
i can't live in
you know they don't want me i'm
undesirable now
there's countries i can't travel to you
know australia
it's a no-go zone i think even canada i
can't really yeah
so you know i'm marked for life in that
regard can never own a firearm again
there's a lot of things that i can't do
i can apply to like vote again
i don't vote don't care about voting but
um
but pretty much once you go down that
path and once you make that mistake
your prison sentence is just the start
of it it never really ends right when i
got out
i had a great job interview more than
qualified as a marketing director
position in columbus ohio
paid 160 000 a year i was hands down the
best person for the job
i went through the first interview they
loved me went through the second
interview with the executives they loved
me
got to the third interview it was they
already made a contingent job offer
yeah with hr they were vetting me
running me through the background check
i said i think at this time i should
give you full disclosure i just got out
of federal prison
whoa wait a minute pump the brakes we
can't hire you
and it just doesn't make any sense to me
yeah you like the person
you know that you know their portfolio
speaks for themselves that you know that
they can do what you need done
properly you know that they meet your
culture demands like they're going to be
a good fit for your company
and you find out that they went to
prison for drug trafficking and
get out of our office is that what your
charge was drug trafficking
drug drug trafficking conspiracy that
was what was the actual charge like with
verbatim
drug trafficking conspiracy yeah that's
what they charge you with
did they get you with like an amount or
anything uh yeah 100 they they just
threw a number out there 100 kilograms
100 kilograms
so what do they call it they uh
methylone
bk hyphen mdma so they actually seized
200 and or 300 i forget
284 kilos i think in the mail
so that's what they actually seized in
one shipment
and it was all going to addresses that
were linked to me
and so that was we'll talk make sure you
yep
so uh so you know that's how they say
the invest
investigation culminated was through
that seizure
of course it didn't it started way
before that
um but that's that's the gist of it
then you know what's funny is the the
girl i'm dating right now she has a lot
of law enforcement in her family
and her family is adamant on her not
dating me
they think i'm some big dangerous drug
trafficker
one of her brother-in-laws said if you
choose
this lifestyle like what does that mean
if you choose this lifestyle
we're disowning you you're not allowed
to see your niece and nephew anymore
you're not welcome at our house
and she says but he's not trafficking
drugs he hasn't he has an app
it's a it's a c corporation in delaware
he has employees he has revenue
it's all done legally and he said well
you know if he was doing like hard
physical labor
like i just don't believe it he thinks
that contractor plus is some way for me
to launder drug money
or wash drug money i would never touch
drugs again
i don't care to use them i don't care to
sell them but convincing someone who
is in that line of work of that is is
difficult you know
yeah uh matt talks a lot a lot about his
troubles trying to uh
make friends and meet new people and
people judging him for his past
dude it's hard have you ever seen orange
as the new black yeah i was so like the
first two seasons
the last season is actually really
important because it shows piper's
reintegration into society it shows her
interaction with her probation officer
it shows the struggle she has finding
employment maintaining employment
dude i never thought it would be a
problem as soon as i got i had an
internship in college
at 111 records as soon as i completed
um as soon as i got my degree i applied
for one job
and i got that job as a web designer a
web developer which is not what i went
to school for yeah but
so i got that job within six months i'm
running that business and another
business owned by that guy
another six months later i'm giving
equity i'm promoted to vice president
i'm running the whole business uh you
know and i ran that business for almost
seven years
yeah so finding it finding employment
has never been a struggle for me i
started my first business at 13.
before i ever went to college i started
working as a e-commerce director
i think i was 18 17 years old 18 years
old in pittsburgh at
um at action fanatics
and so and then so they're like a
paintball distributor
uh jeff lizzick owned that company
brilliant man by the way he's jeff liske
he owns a marketing company now in
pittsburgh and he's been buying up
smaller marketing companies
uh he's been kind of like a mentor to me
uh he believed in me when i was 17 years
old
i remember i got a call from him and he
i was working i was talking shelves at
office max and he said do you know who i
am and i said no
and he said well where are you at right
now and i told him and he laughed and he
was like
dude he was like i saw the website you
built for the paintball team
in uh columbus and he said the
it was an indoor paintball field he said
i saw the website that you built and
it was just immaculate it was awesome
dude and i need you to come to
pittsburgh how quick can you come to
pittsburgh
i think he gave me like 25 bucks an hour
you know that's that's pretty good pay
for
17 year old kid hell yeah so i went to
pittsburgh i built their new website we
migrated to an e-commerce platform
called amphopia
a couple months later that company our
our main supplier key action sports in
sewell new jersey owned by a guy named
gino posterivo one of the biggest
the biggest brand in the sport of
paintball
they offered they called jeff and said
who built your new website
and so they called jeff and they told
him to come
to sewell new jersey and to brain me
so i go to pittsburgh get in the car
with jeff and we drive across the state
of pennsylvania
and uh they pulled us in the conference
room separately
first together and then separately and
they made job offers
and because of my age they offered me i
think 35 grand a year and i told them no
i said you know my age has nothing to do
with it i'm making more money than that
right now
right so but you're gonna have 10 people
working for you you know this is just a
starting pay
they try to sell me on the opportunity
and i said well i haven't went to
college yet you know i want to go to
college
and jeff uh they offered him like 185
a year um and like a 10-year contract he
told him no as well
so um you know just
pretty interesting at that point i said
it was a pivotal moment i said you know
what
i'm going to college i want to go to
full sail going to college in orlando
and i up and moved to orlando and
that's when life began pretty crazy
you